how do you think about the consumer like
the retail consumer getting involved in
mining
versus big guys
it's pretty exciting i think um we're
gonna see i i believe we're gonna see
especially in cold um cold regions or
climates um you know the rise of the
home miner um you know some very very
savvy kind of engineers or or bitcoiners
if you want to say i've been doing this
already but the reality is you know
these these miners kick off a lot of
excess heat
and so doing it uh somewhere that's
pretty cold is actually you know you can
kind of get a two for one where you're
you're mining bitcoin and you're
producing a lot of excess uh energy and
heat and that byproduct can actually you
know heat your home so it's like almost
two birds with one stone and so um it's
something that actually i'm i am
exploring currently uh but i think we'll
see that a lot and it'll kind of just
become i think square's working on that
right they're working on building that
out and they're
in their app as well as working on an
asic so um that would be pretty exciting
and i think we're a little bit away from
kind of that that becoming the standard
but it would be awesome to see uh in you
know coming five years or so i agree
what i also think would be really
interesting i don't think i've seen one
yet that seems viable and commercial
is when you start to get uh anything
that plugs into uh some sort of
electricity and it mines bitcoin in its
off hours so like i'll use a super
egregious
almost absurd example but like you could
see it happening
is somebody builds like a microwave when
it's plugged in
uh it's pulling a little bit of power
right because i was obviously able to
display the time and that type of stuff
but is there a world where the microwave
pays for itself by being able to mine
bitcoin even though it's got very little
computing power right so like that's the
agrees example like okay now walk it
back into well what happens if all of a
sudden you're able to take other things
like the tesla power wall may be a good
example right if they were essentially
able to say hey look we're going to use
renewable power that's stored in this
battery and we're going to take that and
then build kind of a mining component to
it and you can actually hey when you're
not consuming the power if you don't uh
if you're running out or
of capacity or something just go ahead
and almost like burn it but you're
burning it by using it to drive some
sort of monetary value and help secure
the decentralized bitcoin network
like again
go ahead
it's pretty interesting i think bitcoin
mining kind of will will you know almost
like flatten out these um these
disparities and energy prices across the
world right you're seeing um you know
you're seeing a huge energy crisis in
europe right so uh bitcoin miners in
europe currently um they're they're
probably not going to be um on full tilt
right they're gonna they're gonna
instead sell their their energy to the
grid right you're seeing a lot of like
you know grid miners that um like in
texas per se um that are that are
establishing this base load uh energy
demand and then when demand spikes they
turn off and so you can see that kind of
at a micro level right where say maybe
not a microwave but say a water heater
right so um a lot of these things are
you know continuing to be be built out
and there's engineers all over the world
kind of working on this stuff um bitcoin
mining uh with immersion cooling right
it's kind of like
these these ideas that are coming out of
nowhere and they're you know they're
really fascinating and i i mean we're
just scratching the surface in terms of
what can be done uh with kind of this
this newfound
demand or ability to take energy from
anywhere uh and and turn it into sound
money and so i think the applications
and the the you know the engineering uh
you know feats that will be built on top
of this and around this network uh is
something that i i can't fathom and i'll
let other people figure that out